people are not in a panic in the way
that they should be it means it's very
dire times so I felt like how to do
something and so we set up this panel
drop and I just feel really lucky to be
surrounded by so many amazing activists
that are dedicating their their time to
raising awareness about the mean dairy
industries in Padgett armatures the
message that you want people to go away
with today I think sometimes we defer
responsibility to our governments or
organizations I think we have a personal
responsibility to take action right now
and one way that we can mitigate climate
change is by adjusting our consumption
right and by going plant-based and so I
feel sometimes like that's not being
talked about enough and some just
encouraging people to learn more about
about eating plant-based and to make a
difference to to to make whatever
personal impact they can on climate
change on the climate emergency I have
been vegan since I was three years old
but I I think the my activism has has
slowly grown I wish I'd been more active
when I was when I was younger but I've
been exposed to so many incredible
activists in the last few years and it's
really galvanized my own activism I
think when you when you witness the
horror that really happens behind closed
doors and slaughterhouses to farm
animals all over the world it's
impossible not to be affected by it and
to realize that we have to do something
drastic to
so I'm just doing my part and trying to
amplify the the voice of these activists
that are out every day doing something
taking action and it's the least I could
do is to take some time off today and
come here to talk about this issue
speaks to raise this issue and to kind
of galvanize the film community are they
responding and are they responding quick
enough they are responding it's been
incredible to see the domino effect
after the Golden Globes the Critics
Choice Awards new plant-based and the
star awards one plant-based you know
which we're trying but no it's not
enough because I can't stress this
enough
this is an emergency right now right
mama so we have to do everything that we
can to try to cut down on our impact on
climate change but it's it's more than
than it has been in the past I think
people are more curious I've experienced
this in my own life so many people
people that I've known for years that
I've talked about veganism with that
warm responsive now are asking me more
about it so there is there is progress
and certainly compared to when I became
vegan in 1977 there are huge strides
have you said that people need to take
personal responsibility in it
not just about government but do you
think governments are doing enough is
your governments doing enough but we'll
get there even in your position
high-profile people are often kind of
accused of hypocrisy and when they're
talking about climate change because you
fly so much you travel so much and how
do you kind of respond to criticism so I
wanted you offset
well we're you're all pitched in some
ways right we all struggle with what the
right thing to do is and we make
mistakes but I think that the one thing
that I can do right now does consume a
lot of power it consumes a lot of
resources right so the way to mitigate
that for me is to maintain a vegan
lifestyle right so I think that that's
what we can do and that was I think the
are appealed to the the award ceremonies
there are so many people that are flying
into the awards they're driving the cars
they're the one thing that you could do
is to make the meal plant-based so I
think we just try to find that balance
nobody's perfect but we're all trying to
figure it out right I think instead of
being judgmental and attacking each
other we should try to help each other
and educate each other about how we can
change and there's certainly many things
that I need to do many improvements that
I can make my own personal life and I'm
trying to do that and I encourage people
to to talk to me about that right and to
educate me right because I don't know
everything I'm just trying to figure it
out also right and I hope that we can
just be open to to each other and really
hear each other and hear the importance
of this message